with John Wick 4 on the horizon it's
worth taking a look back at the making
of the first three films in the
franchise to see how a single action
movie spawned an entire Legacy Keanu
Reeves has appeared in plenty of famous
films but is most widely known role is
without a doubt Neo and the Matrix
series The wachowski's layered Universe
set new standards for action movies and
gave pop culture one of its most iconic
theories about alternate realities as
Neo the mystical one destined to take
down the machines holding humankind
hostage reefs established himself as a
true action star that made him the ideal
choice to play one of the world's most
lethal Hitmen in John Wick
okay
what do you need
[Music]
guns
lots of guns Beyond Keanu the John Wick
and Matrix film series have quite a few
casting crew members in common the two
directors of the first film David Leach
and Chad stachelski were stuntmen in The
Matrix the second film in the series
John Wick chapter 2 reunited Reeves with
Lawrence Fishburne who many people know
as Neo's Mentor Morpheus Die Hard Matrix
fans may have caught another Cameo as
well Randall duck Kim who played the key
maker in The Matrix Reloaded is a doctor
in the first and third Wick films
finally John Wick chapter 3 features in
exchange between Jon and Winston that
fans of the Matrix may very well
recognize what do you need
guns
lots of guns Keanu Reeves had plenty of
creative input on John Wick working
closely with writer Derek Kolstad to
flesh out his mysterious character
keeping in mind Reeves famously generous
nature it's no surprise that he turned
two former crew members from The Matrix
to help him create a great action film
specifically David Leach and Chad
stachelski though Reeves initially
reached out to the two veteran fight
choreographers and stuntmen to see if
they would simply design the film's
action he hoped they would direct and
luckily for Reeves they were more than
happy to take on the challenge having
worked with Keanu plenty of times before
leech and stahlski were familiar with
both his prowess and his process which
made stunts and fights on WIC much more
seamless both leech and stahelski have
credited their work on The Matrix as an
inspiration for John Wick as well as a
Guiding Light for their overall careers
stahelski told vulture after the Matrix
I went from an average stunt guy to one
of the biggest choreographers in the
business I started a company that deals
specifically with martial arts
choreography and that's grown into all
the John Wick movies and everything The
Matrix literally changed the industry in
the late 80s and early 90s Keanu Reeves
transitioned away from doing goofy
comedies like Bill and Ted's Excellent
Adventure and started doing action films
like Point Break and speed nowadays he's
an experienced stunt man in his own
right he studied countless fighting
techniques and performed many of his own
stunts throughout his storied career
John Wick is no exception to prepare for
John Wick leech and stahlski insisted
that Reeves not used any of his previous
martial arts knowledge instead learning
entirely new methods of combat for the
movie as a result he spent months
training with veterans from SWAT teams
as well as former Navy Seals Reeves went
on to do a large amount of the stunts
seen in John Wick and most of them with
no double in John Wick 2. the third Wick
contained even more death-defying acts
from Reeves proving that even as he ages
he's still more than capable of stunning
audiences with his stunt work and his
complete commitment to what has now
become one of his signature roles the
John Wick franchise makes some obvious
nonstick classic action and martial arts
movies but the films also find
inspiration in Greek mythology in 2020 2
Series director Chad stachalski told
variety you know we've always seen Jon
as Odysseus
Odysseus of course is the Greek hero of
the Odyssey who left home to fight in
the Trojan War and didn't find his way
home for 20 years like Odysseus Jon has
found himself going more than a bit off
course and his adventures have put him
in contact with some mythological
figures with memorable personalities
Karen played by Lance Reddick works the
front desk of the continental and he has
a knack for finding whatever guests
might need be it high-powered Weaponry
or a discreet doctor Karen's name comes
straight from Greek mythology the
ancient Karen is the fairy man of the
River Styx faded to help Souls proceed
to the afterlife for all of eternity the
two Karens have more in common than you
might see at first glance both help
people travel through the city
underbelly of the world and both accept
gold coins as payment for their services
much like his mythological counterpart
Karen and the John Wick series is a man
of few words and many Secrets how did he
come to be part of John's world of
Assassins with any luck it's a topic to
be addressed in a future movie or spin
off
and as always
it is a pleasure having you with us
again
Mr weak the John Wick franchise wouldn't
be what it is today without a massive
team of talented people working together
but the story itself wouldn't exist
without Derek colstad before 2014's John
Wick changed his career forever colstad
had spent years grinding his way through
Hollywood trying to make it as a
screenwriter his earliest films include
One in the Chamber and the package but
selling those did nothing to prepare
Kolstad for his future success John Wick
started as a screenplay called scorn but
that changed pretty quickly once Keanu
Reeves signed on to play the lead he
convinced Kolstad to change not just the
film's title but also the name of its
main character John Wick is an
undeniably cool name but Reeves and
colstad didn't come up with it at random
no it's actually the name of colstad's
Grandfather who's never seen any of the
films how do you get an audience to root
for a merciless Hitman aside from
casting one of Hollywood's most beloved
actors in the role the first John Wick
movie solved the problem by giving its
leading man an adorable co-star as fans
of John Wick know Jon's wife left him
Daisy the Beagle after she died she
hoped that by having something to love
and care for Jon would be able to hold
on to the quiet peaceful life that the
two of them had built together Jon and
Daisy have an immediate connection but
some behind the scenes magic went into
making that relationship feel genuine
Reeves had bacon grease smeared on his
face so the puppy wouldn't be able to
resist jumping on him and licking him
what happened to the puppy after John
Wick robbed is just as sweet his name
was Andy and for a while he lived at the
animal actors International Farm but he
was way too cute to stay there for long
eventually a family adopted Andy and
renamed him Wick so he'll always have a
close tie to the movie that made him a
star there are few actors as dedicated
to their craft as Keanu Reeves after all
he does most of his own stunts and that
doesn't just apply to his work in the
John Wick franchise when he was filming
The Matrix resurrections Reeves jumped
off for building almost two dozen times
in his efforts to get the perfect shot
for the film Reeves is well into his 50s
now but that hasn't stopped him from
learning intricate martial arts
Maneuvers and moving through lengthy
fight sequences while working on the
original John Wick in particular Reeves
went above and beyond what was being
asked of him one of the film's most
complicated scenes involves Jon battling
through an entire nightclub full of
baddies in the director's commentary on
the film stahlski let it slip that
Reeves had the flu during his time
filming that particular scene Reeves
apparently had a 103 degree fever over
the two days it took to put the entire
nightclub sequence together even though
people urged him to stop and take a
break Reeves refused pushing his way
through shot after shot of what would
become the film's most successful action
set piece with so many epic stunts and
intense fight scenes filming any high
octane action movie can be potentially
dangerous but what happened to actor
Mikhail neek Feast is on another level
Nick Beast played Vigo tarasov in the
original John Wick film he's the man who
let Jon walk out of the criminal
underworld and the disappointed father
of the dog Hiller Yosef who has to be
defended against the movie's titular
assassin let us not resort to our baser
instincts and handle this like civilized
man to move on
from his imposing presence to his
fashion sense Vico is a Russian mobster
through and through but the Hat he wears
in some scenes may have been less about
showing off his style and more about
covering up the aftermath of a terrible
onset injury while working on the movie
Nick vist accidentally got knocked into
a window frame so hard that he nearly
lost his ear and had to be rushed to the
emergency room it took 80 stitches but a
plastic surgeon was able to put Nick
Beast back together luckily he was just
fine and the hat his character wore in
the film concealed the stitches while
his injury healed sadly though nikves
passed away from lung cancer three years
after John Wick's release at the age of
56. Mikhail Nick viest wasn't the only
actor to suffer an injury during the
production of a John Wick movie as Halle
Berry also found herself in some serious
pain during her time on set Barry joined
the world of WIC in 2019's John Wick
chapter 3 Parabellum as Sophia l azwar a
professional killer with a team of
terrifying trained dogs
sit
was talking to you John
like Keanu Reeves Barry went all in when
it came to training for the film she
went through a quasi-hit-man boot camp
learning a wide range of fighting
techniques gun skills and animal
handling tips to bring Sophia to life
the Oscar winner also learned some
demanding choreography for her scenes
and during those hours of training and
fighting Barry broke three of her ribs
her biggest concern however was that
taking time to heal would cause her part
to be recast fortunately for all
involved the wick team was able to wait
for Barry to get back into fighting
shape allowing her to go on to become
one of the most memorable supporting
talents in the entire franchise
Keanu Reeves has been an action star for
a long time he first learned Kung Fu as
Neo in The Matrix in 1999 but almost a
decade before that he was jumping out of
a plane as undercover FBI agent Johnny
Utah in Point Break needless to say
Keanu knows how to throw a punch and
perform a stunt but even more
importantly he knows how to train and
take care of himself while learning new
moves understandably Reeves has needed
to adapt the way he trains as the years
have progressed in the lead-up to The
Matrix he suffered a back injury and had
to have his spine fused he was still
recovering while filming and in some
behind the scenes footage he's fighting
while wearing a neck brace nowadays
Reeves doesn't have to contend with such
a serious injury and he's all but
perfected his own physical training
program he has a simple secret to
keeping his body in fighting condition
he told today in 2014 you take really
cold ice baths every night
Keanu Reeves may be the face and name of
the John Wick franchise but over the
years fans have become just as attached
to the unique world and mythology of the
series as they have to its main
character for anyone interested in the
deeper workings of the Assassin
underground there's never been a better
time to be a John Wick fan I'm a huge
fan
John Wick
before you haven't disappointed
the spin-off TV show the Continental
will act as a prequel to the first film
while also bringing the world of John
Wick into a new medium there's enough
going on at New York's Premier hotel for
Assassins to fuel multiple seasons of
Television but the franchise is also
planning an expanded presence on the big
screen as well the John Wick spin-off
movie ballerina is still something of a
mystery but it is known that it will
take a deeper look at the murderous
ballet troop introduced in John Wick
chapter 3. Anna De armas will star as
Rooney Brown a trained killer seeking
revenge on the people who killed her
family John Wick will also be making an
appearance in the film but how he
factors into the plot or how this movie
will impact his own story remains a
mystery if you've ever watched a John
Wick movie and wished you could be part
of the action you're not alone every
movie in the series has the Hallmarks of
a great video game henchmen a boss level
wild shootouts but sadly Gamers have had
few opportunities to try out some gun fu
for themselves John Wick hex is the only
game thus far that has attempted to
deliver on the experience of becoming
everyone's favorite gunslinging Hitman
developed by Bissell games hex is a
top-down tactical strategy game that has
players leading Jon through one group of
armed guards after another because it's
a strategy game hex moves a bit slower
than a typical John Wick action scene
unfortunately and It ultimately doesn't
quite manage to translate Jon's
experiences into a playable format
yeah not really luckily there's still a
strong possibility that fans are
eventually going to get the John Wick
game they deserve during an earnings
call in late 2022 Lionsgate CEO John
feldheimer indicated that the company is
very interested in producing a major AAA
game based on the John Wick franchise
there are no concrete plans for a game
just yet but the company seems
interested in finding a developer worthy
of the IP considering how many more John
Wick spin-offs Lionsgate has in the
works they clearly don't intend on
slowing down with the franchise anytime
soon
[Music]
thank you